Scientists are saying they found gravitational waves from the big bang,...
...giving us a look into what our universe was like only 380,000 years into its existence.
They're calling the discovery as big as it gets.
Hey everybody, I'm Patrick Jones and welcome to Buzz 60.
The discovery and analyzing of these gravitational waves...
...are proof the big bang was really the kickoff of it all.
Gravitational waves are very tiny ripples in space-time,...
...originally predicted by Mr. Albert Einstein in 1916.
They've never been detected before now.
Researchers from Harvard University made the discovery...
...using the BICEP2 telescopes in Antarctica.
The waves supposedly line up with the sudden brief...
...and very violent period of our universe's expansion called "inflation".
More than one scientist is saying the work is Nobel-worthy.
We'll see, but it's definitely a "we'll open the good bottle of wine" discovery.